welcome back to cbs mornings more
documents released in a major new
investigation reveal how the u.s has
become a banking haven for wealthy
people all around the world the pandora
papers is what they're calling it the
report shows how five states allowed
people in other countries to set up
trust and hide huge sums of money now
the report identifies more than 330
politicians and ultra rich people
including some accused of criminal
activity who use these offshore tax
havens in this country abroad
in this country and abroad to shield
money and assets it's based on nearly 12
million confidential documents think
about that number for just a second
detailing more than 29 000 offshore
accounts
greg miller of the washington post post
joins us now from london he was part of
the international team of journalists
from multiple outlets who worked on this
report greg miller first let's say kudos
to you and your team because what you've
uncovered has unleashed quite the
conversation normally opening pandora's
box is not a good thing and that's the
case here we welcome you from london
today
thank you
can you tell us how this was allowed to
happen in the first place how people
were able to do it and why they were
doing it
so i mean the offshore system has been
around for many many years in some ways
it's uh it's actually grown and expanded
as new jurisdictions compete with
existing jurisdictions to offer more
secrecy more ways to hide money
and it's very resilient there have been
many efforts over the years to try to
impose greater transparency in banking
to demand reforms of governments
that shelter assets
but it's been an uphill climb and i
think these latest stories show that
that we're a long way from achieving
that
but it's my understanding it's not
illegal is it
no i mean much of it is not illegal so
these companies you know these are
jurisdictions say the british virgin
islands or in singapore or other places
where there are companies that biting by
those those print those jurisdictions
laws
can set up shell companies can set up
trusts that are almost impenetrable
where you can hide assets it's how they
end up being used that is usually the
problem you can hide illegal gains you
can hide proceeds from corruption you
can hide assets from creditors
uh or even family members and it's
almost impossible to get to and that's
what that's a big part of the problem
you know all the numbers show that most
people in this country a don't have a
savings account
be or are thinking this is this is a
rich person's problem or rich person's
game rather so if i'm sitting at home
and i'm watching you and i'm trying to
just make ends meet living paycheck to
paycheck why should i care about this
how does this affect me
i think it affects ordinary people in
many many ways it takes away tax
revenues that would otherwise help to
pay for services in the in the countries
where we live including in the united
states uh it uh it actually
enables many categories of crime from
drug trafficking to political corruption
it makes it harder for us to hold
politicians accountable when politicians
skirt the law
and and uh engage in corruption and
pocket uh payments they have ways to
hide it that make it very difficult to
find and that undermines our democracy
that undermines good governance so it
affects us all in many many ways
greg this has been described as a
parallel financial universe with
corrosive effects that could span
generations how so
well it contributes to a lot of problems
that are really endemic and that are
growing right now including you know
wealth disparities in this in the united
states and in other countries when when
the wealthiest have the ability to hide
much of their money in jurisdictions
where they're not paying the same tax
rates they would otherwise that helps
them hold on to that wealth and grow
that wealth whereas those who are less
fortunate are paying their share if not
more and making up for that difference
so it contributes to a lot of issues
that that actually get worse the longer
that this persists
what's the solution greg
well it's very difficult i mean the the
united states many we've had president
after president condemn
uh the offshore system but even in the
united states as we report in the post
there are states including south dakota
nevada alaska that are increasingly
passing
financial secrecy laws of their own that
and
effectively function as offshore havens
within the united states uh part of the
problem is that this is this is a
banking system or a financial system
that takes advantage of the fact that
money moves past national borders so
it's hard for any country or even a
group of countries to gain much headway
yeah there were a lot of well-known
names on this list but there were no
americans
no that's not true there are some
americans but not the most wealthy
americans not jeff bezos for example
or mark zuckerberg or facebook they
don't show up in the documents that
could be because these documents came
from financial services companies in 14
places around the world
that america's wealthiest people just
don't use or perhaps american
billionaires are doing other things with
their money besides putting them in
shell companies or trusts in these
offshore systems that we're writing
about
all right thank you greg as you said
it's not uh it's not illegal but the
optics sure don't look good or feel good
to be honest with you thank you
thank you very much for your time this
morning thanks